this is a production of cornell
university
um anyway so this project is looking at
what makes a maize plant competitive for
resources
versus potentially more cooperative
in the long run and i'm also interested
in trying to understand how different
growth strategies can impact a
neighboring plant
and so plan to plant interactions are
everywhere within the field and they can
have an impact on neighboring phenotypes
where for instance a competition within
the field
could cause extensive yield variation
where if you see here we have more
cooperative plants in a uniform stand
you would see these limited neighbor
effects versus if you have more
competitive plants
you're going to have a more uneven stand
in the field
and larger neighbor effects which could
impact yield variation
now selection dynamics may play a role
in competitive ability
and as we've moved from more of a
historically individual selection
dynamic to more of group
selection as we've moved more towards
modern hybrids
we may have seen overall selection for
more cooperative plants
however even in our modern breeding
schemes and inbred line developments
we are still seeing early selection on
individual plants within
the field that later on moves to
selections on rows
or group selection now
with this we might have inadvertently
been selecting for
competitive plants early on in our
breeding schemes
and more cooperative plants later on as
we start doing our yield trial
evaluations
so despite over a century of this
selection
we still get extensive field variation
within our field of genetically
identical genotypes
and competition for resources may be a
driver of this yield variation
and although we know from different
ecological studies what traits are
linked to competitive ability we do not
yet know
to what extent these traits are really
playing a role
and how different combinations of traits
or growth strategies
affect a neighboring plant now
my hypothesis is that traits relating to
resource capture
will have the largest competitive effect
on their neighbors
and additionally the response of
neighboring plants will vary depending
on their own grass
growth strategy and so of particular
interest to me
are these four traits highlighted here
plant height leaf length leaf width
and leaf angle and i will be focusing on
them for the next portion
of my presentation so
neighboring rows have been known to
impact the phenotype
of a particular row being measured which
is why historically
four row plots are very commonly used in
the field when trying to
get an accurate estimate of yield of
plants
and within a yield trial so in order to
better understand the importance of
different traits
and growth strategies measuring these
potential neighbor effects and
field experiments where a different
genotype was planted
in each row could provide an initial
look into competition dynamics
and so the maize nam population was
grown
in this method where we had a unique
genotype
in each row and by looking at this
population i have the ability to look
directly at five
thousand genotypes across eight
locations
and in today's example looking
particularly at four different
traits to evaluate these different
neighbor effects
now by using this data i am able to
estimate the genotype means via blops or
geb fees
and then incorporate the neighbor row
effects and
ultimately predict performance so a
really
simplified model could look something
like this where
i'm predicting plant height of say this
row 2
by predicting the height of the self row
or row 2
using blubs and then taking the average
blob
of rows 1 and 3 and seeing how
those neighbors affect my prediction for
the plant height of this central row
and this model can be extended to
include
multiple traits uh beyond just height so
things such as leaf length leaf width
the other traits i was discussing
earlier
so i end up generating linear models for
each population
and each environment kind of following
the general
formula shown here just for plant height
so
looking at you know the bluff for the
central row and then the block for
the neighboring rows and the betas so
the weights were evaluated
for their significance and so i ended up
looking at this
beta of your neighboring value over the
beta of
the self or central row value to really
start to look at what is the importance
of the neighbors
relative to this central row and so
shown here is a plot where i have
all of the different populations and
the significance or the importance of
the beta neighbor over the beta itself
and
so as you're looking at this these lines
going across
are the general significance thresholds
where
the beta of the neighbor had a
significant term within the model and
as we move away from zero in either
direction
that means that the neighboring plants
are more important in actually
predicting
our height of the central row and so you
can see a lot of it is clustering around
zero but there is some variation so that
was of potential interest to me
and that being said the significant
neighbor traits did end up varying by
population and environment
so in making a more complex model that
included these four traits here leaf
angle leaf length leaf width and plant
height
i went ahead and plotted out the
number of significant neighbor traits
within the models
for each location with the dotted line
showing the null
expectation of how many would occur by
random chance
and of interest to me was that new york
in
2006 i had a much higher
level than new york in 2007 and the
difference between
these two years was that in 2006
all the the field itself was planted
in blocks by population while in new
york in 2007
the field was planted in blocks by
flowering time so that means
plants that were of a similar height
were grown next to each other
and when breaking this down and looking
further
at the importance of neighbor traits
just within
a population across all locations again
with the dotted line showing our null
expectation value you can see that some
lines like b97 here
did not have any significant neighbor
effects
for these four traits while other lines
like the cml
228 had much larger neighbor effects
now while historical data exists for
between row measurements
there is you know little to no data for
within row
unique mixtures of hybrids and so by
mixing hybrids with different growth
strategies my goal is to start to
distinguish what
traits are most important towards a
plant being competitive or cooperative
and can we start to identify say a
cooperative mixture
versus a more competitive mixture
and so this past summer i grew a mixed
plot experiment where
32 hybrids were grown in unique
combinations
to evaluate the effects of neighboring
plants within a row
so these plants were grown both in mixed
and in single hybrid plots
and at the end of the season i use the
single hybrid plots to predict the yield
of the mixed hybrids
so by looking at the distribution and
total plot level yield
i can start to evaluate the impact that
different growth strategies have
on neighboring individuals so shown here
would be the hypothetical example
of hybrid a and hybrid b and their
resulting yield distribution
and overall plot level yield
and upon mixing hybrid a
and hybrid b you can see that in this
hypothetical scenario the yield per
hybrid
is approximately the same as what you
would
see with the two single hybrid plots and
our overall plot level yield
remains constant so in this case we
would say that the hybrids have
cooperative
growth strategies and are not seeing any
sort of yield penalty
however say we're growing a hybrid a and
hybrid b
together and hybrid a ends up being much
taller than hybrid b
and shades out its neighbors you can see
that we've now seen a shift in our yield
distribution
and that the overall plot level yield is
lower
so in this case i would say that there
is actually competition
between the growth strategies in this
mixture
and so looking at my actual data and
predicting mixed plot hybrid yield from
the means of the single hybrid plots
i found that the actual mixed plot yield
is able to be predicted
rather well in this scenario and it
shows that the hybrids are performing
similarly in mixed plots as they do in
the single
hybrid plots now given that i only have
one field season and a limited amount of
data from this
i definitely do need more field seasons
and data
to draw more solid conclusions as to
whether there are
some hybrids that perform generally the
same in mixture
or better or if they're always
performing worse in mixture
as they do compared when they're grown
in a single hybrid plot
so currently what i'm seeing is that
competitive ability
does not appear to have a large impact
in these plant plant interactions for
u.s improved lines but come the 2021
field season
i will be growing this mixed plot
experiment in five genomes to fields
locations
so i have a large amount of data there
that i can start to look at
additionally i'm further expanding upon
my between row models by looking at
hybrid data
since the nam data was all on inbreds
and i'm curious if there's a difference
between inverts and hybrids
and additionally i'm further
investigating these traits on the
hybrids in my 2020 data set
to really see if perhaps there's
different contrasting traits
or if there's any sort of impact there
that could be of interest
and so at this point i would like
to thank the buckler lab as well as
the robin's lab and my committee members
for all their assistance so far
and i would be happy to take any
questions
great talk amy thank you very much um
and yes please uh if you have questions
for amy either
type them in the chat um and
feel free to unmute yourself and read
them or i can read them
or raise your hand so it looks like
we've got a question from
mike gore mike if you would like to
talk please feel free yeah i'm happy to
very nice presentation amy do you think
older hybrids developed under
low density selection would perform more
poorly under mixed planting
that's an excellent question
i think a big factor you'd have to
consider would be
the density that you would be growing
under
a mixed planting experiment if we were
growing them under
you know a modern planting density i
would say they would
perform poorly because you know there
are a lot of studies that have been done
just talking about the density
adaptation that's occurred
with older hybrids um but at a lower
density
you know that i guess i'm not quite sure
what i would expect to see
other than perhaps you know maybe there
would be more
competition just because as we say you
know we've
increased the density we've increased
the cooperativeness of our plants
um so i guess that's maybe more what i
would expect to see
but i think that would be a great thing
to test out
cool thank you amy do we have
any other questions for amy
uh rebecca nelson has a question hi yeah
i wanted to thank both speakers for
great presentations
um i was wondering um to amy if i got
you right that you did have some
evidence of
rotor row competition and you will come
look at these morphological
um variables that might explain that and
i was wondering if you might also have
chemical
mechanisms in mind like they're sort of
olympic type
chemical ecological type ways that
plants might try to
squelch their their neighbors and was
there any sort of unexplained
competition that might be explicable by
that kind of mechanism
yeah so i didn't really account for
or look at non-morphological
uh factors within the models but there
definitely has been
some more recent literature that's come
out showing that
you know there definitely could be some
sort of you know
chemical type mechanisms uh i would
expect to see that more within a row
versus looking between rows as you're
going to have
you know more direct interactions
looking at roots um
within a row and so that could
definitely be
something of interest to look at but it
is not
you know something i probably will be
able to do in the scope of this project
in itself but
you know based off of some of these
papers i do suspect that
you know there absolutely could be
something going on either
with the root exudates um or
like root interactions i should say not
necessarily exudates
that could potentially cause differences
in interactions
but was there a bit of unexplained
variation with that that might
was left after you accounted for the
morphological um
i guess i i would need to go back and
look a little bit further at the models
because i definitely i only went out to
four traits
um and in the future do you want to
include more so i mean there's
definitely in the sense of
you know our my predictive abilities
with these four traits
perfect they're definitely not um so you
know
there are more factors absolutely that
we can look at
okay um thank you rebecca for the
question
and we have a question from ricky
techmeyer
ricky do you want to ask that out loud
hi um yeah so i was just curious if
in a mix system with different hybrids
all having
different expressions of different um
chemical recruiters in the soil
would have uh an effect on what kind of
profile of soil microbes you could
accumulate in that system yeah so that's
a great question and one i've actually
been talking to or
asking of some different soil people and
amazed people studying like microbiomes
and
kind of the general consensus that i
have heard
um although it's definitely up for
debate still
is that within a single field season
probably growing unique
mixtures wouldn't have a huge impact on
the soil
microbiome but perhaps grown over a
longer period of time
maybe you could see some differences um
so i guess that's that's what i've heard
and i've discussed with people
um but who knows there are there's a lot
of people studying just how
you know a single hybrid could have a
different microbiome than another hybrid
in a field so
i think the argument could be made that
other way too
all right thank you okay
um i don't see any more questions for
amy
at the moment um i'd like to open a last
chance questions for either of our
speakers here
um but other than that we're out of time
so please
remember to fill out the feedback forms
for our speakers
and thank you jack and amy for wonderful
presentations today
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu